good morning everyone the first talk of
today is by Jason Lee Corporation
University of audacious of departing
star customer meetings and over
characterization and transition yeah so
of course obviously deep learning super
successful at blah blah blah it solves a
lot of stuff it's successful in a lot of
things some people I've even gone as far
as claiming it's the new electricity of
course when we have electricity we
should look there's a field call
electrical engineering the studies it I
guess it's kind of a purpose of us being
here this summer so deep learning is not
quite a science yet it's fairly crazy
that things regardless of whether these
things where people will try crazy
things like these cyclic learning rates
learning rate to nice games are pretty
crazy they're fragile even things like
changing seeds and it's sort of like
we're trying to build a working system
by trial and error instead of
understanding something like civil
engineering and then sort of you know
been our deep learner has built this
thing but you didn't take a structural
engineering class so that's what
happened so this talk is trying to about
unkind understand deep learning so
motivate of course by this well-known
paper I added an optimization at the end
I think they forgot that they left out
something pretty important there okay so
understanding deep learning and we so
there's obviously two aspects our goal
is to minimize test error we want to do
say multi-class classification as usual
you can think of as two components an
optimization error and the
generalization error something
controlled by the algorithm and
something simply statistical so there's
of course this problem is challenging in
both aspects the optimizations
non-convex non-smooth the global
landscape right nothing is very good
about it lots of local minima and just
in general it's difficult the reason
about the only thing we can see are
really gradients at Hessians and so
forth local information and you want to
draw global conclusions
on the statistical side similarly bad
there's more parameters than samples
that generalization error literally
depends on everything your algorithm
you're learning race schedule your
architecture initialization scheme
algorithm parameters such as momentum so
forth okay so how to deal with
optimization luckily this is probably
where it's most well understood is
simply people have realized that you can
always change the model that if one
model is difficult to fit we don't have
ever believed any models correct or
anything like that you just fit a bigger
model and bigger models are easier for
SPD to fit which is somewhat of an
empirical fact I know so you can have
this model with many bad local minima do
something and then SGD works so over
privatization okay here's an experiment
showing this this experiment is
essentially replicated from this paper
of living Isha Mirror and she'll have
shorts so on the left hand side the data
comes from a teacher network that's
fairly small compact as 50 neurons on
the learner side the network has doubled
the number new ons there's a hundred
neurons but still the data comes from a
network with only 50 neurons so if you
try to run SGD on the well-specified
architecture which is very sensible
assuming you saw through a statistics
class if the model comes from the family
you want to be well specified Emily's
asymptotically efficient da da da
whatever by the end of the day actually
fails so statistical efficiency doesn't
matter right if you can't get training
our low why do you care about
statistical efficiency because you
cannot find the mo e you run SGD five
times it gets five different answers
none of which are the global minima I
could have done this five thousand times
I don't think you would have found the
global minimum okay now in stark
contrast simply the same data comes from
the same source and I simply change
slightly change the architecture the
only thing is doubling the number of
neurons
and I run STD again five times and every
single time it's lost value zero and
this is also tester
this is STD on fresh cause of data this
is not training here so SGD is finding
the global minima of the population loss
empirically so seemingly over
privatization does in fact make
optimization easier and in this case
even made because it's tests are you
could have even extracted some
statistical statement here okay so
recently in many a series of papers by
myself
yen's it also briefly talked about this
yesterday Trenton has also worked on
this I'm summarizing all of these
results because they're all kind of
similar enough I don't want to spend
time distinguishing they basically say
if you have very wide networks and you
initialize randomly with appropriate
variances that are not crazy gradient
descent converges to an epsilon global
minimizer as long as the loss is convex
your learning rate is small roughly
speaking or works for any model so when
you're sufficiently over privatized you
get an epsilon approximate global
minimizer of the training loss let me
sketch a proof of why this could be true
of course when you're over parametrized
looking at the parameters is not a great
idea they're not identifiable
there's permutations and all sorts of
other invariances that come out that the
parameters don't really respect it's a
better idea to look at how the
prediction changes so if you compute the
change in the loss you'll find that it's
related to the outer product of a
certain Jacobian matrix or though or the
gram matrix as long as this gram matrix
is strictly positive definite you get a
contraction so then if I could ensure
that this thing stayed positive definite
then you convert to a global minimizer
so why does this the first thing is to
establish that it started positive
definite that's pretty clear random
matrices are positive definite so this
is some sort of just a concentration and
perturbation analysis
to show that initialization the gram
matrix state is positive-definite and
then simply when you're very over Prime
Christ M is the width of the networks
then it stays positive definite there's
always hiding a bunch of stuff it's
whatever it's something and then you
need am big enough to make this smaller
than lambda zero okay so over
parameterization essentially what it
does is if it's forcing in this
initialization scheme it's forcing the
grab matrix to stay very stable close to
this initialization and thus stay well
conditioned and finally you get the
great from this you can extract
statements of this type foursquare loss
you can say exactly converges to global
minima at a log 1 over epsilon rate if
this will say logistic loss you could
say that it converges an epsilon global
minimizer where Absalon is determined by
the width if you want in smaller you
would need wider because logistic loss
is not global we strongly come back to
so many locally well regardless for wide
enough networks as long as your loss is
any convex function your you can get a
statement like this ok so after we so
here's a simpler way to interpret these
statements if you don't want to read 15
pages of calculating algebra one way to
interpret these statements is a
statement about the local geometry of
the loss function you take your random
initialization draw a ball around it of
some norms see for some appropriate seat
that depends on the width you set every
critical point in B is a global
minimizer and there's at least one
global minimizer here and Gd store stays
in this set so it's a statement about
local geometry is saying that locally
things essentially look convex as long
as you find a critical point in this
local set it will be a global minimizer
and in fact you do stay in this set
so roughly the global geometry of deep
networks is it's probably pretty bad I
think there's definitely it should have
exponentially many bad local minima
local minima with even high values of
crane loss however locally there is a
global minima locally there exists
global minima and you can find a region
in which there are global minima but no
local minima no local minima of higher
loss yeah
one way is you take in under parametrize
network and start introducing neurons
and then set them to be like to sort of
cancel each other
configure the ways you add them in a way
that cannot help but it's still a local
minima I can make at least I can make it
a higher order saddle up certain but I'm
not saying you'll find them yeah I'm
saying there are ones and certainly not
near random initializing
oh I think I can always do this I take
your architecture I just make a tiny one
if you believe there's one in a very
small architecture I start augmenting
neurons in some useless way so it will
look like a standard architecture but
maybe the parameters will be in a weird
configuration at least I can make a
satellite high order satellite
okay so global geometry probably not
very good local geometry very good there
is a global minima and gradient descent
converges to it so we're kind of happy
and then oh you think about it a little
bit more and then some paper start
coming out and then you realize of
course locally it's very good locally
you can write down any function so f
theta is my neural network function it's
essentially equal to some F 0 it's not
important think of f 0 as 0 or very
close to 0 some order one quantity a
gradient term and a second order term so
of course since I'm local the second
order term should be thought of as
smaller than the delayed the linear term
so we kind of just throw it away and
that's what these papers are doing and
then so what's happening here is that if
you're able to change the predictions f
of X by an order one quantity while the
Jacobian the gradient stay constant in a
relative sense then the second order
term is essentially vanishing the second
order term is how fast this changes so
if I can move f of X by order one which
is all I need to move it because I need
to move it to match Y well this stays
constant then I'm done I've found that
I've constructed a global minimizer that
is very close to my initialization close
in the sense that there's no neg there's
no potential negative curvature and
that's essentially what that proof was
saying it was saying this H of the H
matrix the gram matrix is simply outer
products of these gradients and it was
not moving a lot under these
initialization schemes on widths and so
forth ok so she's out and Bach came up
with a nice sufficient condition of when
you should expect this they call it this
kernel regime to happen
essentially the sufficient condition is
that think of Y minus F 0 as order one
we initialize in network so it outputs
an order one quantity that's random so
this is like 1 because Y is order 1 and
I basically pointed out that if you're
Hessian divided by the square norm of
the gradient is smaller than one then
the second order term doesn't matter and
your gradient dynamics track very
closely for some constant amount of time
the dynamics of a of gradient descent on
a kernel machine this is very intuitive
because it's essentially saying exactly
that how much the Hessian changes is
very small to the gradient and the
gradient when the gradient is big then
you only need to move the parameters a
little bit and you move your predictions
by a lot so roughly in all of the ways
we initialize the Hessian is something
like going to zero with the width and
the gradient is of one and so we have
this sort of linear behavior in some
region around the initialisation okay so
any questions here before I move on to
you saying the final state is an
interpretive approximation an initial
and that this linear approximation is
good is this sort of an idealized model
motivated by a team that works and how
you think about this analysis
appropriate does this change so it was
all like this so I would this result I
would think as if this sufficient
condition holds and you use a very small
learning rate then the gradient on F
theta F theta sub peak and you can
construct a new function that is linear
call it f bar theta T these are very
close for a constant amount of time
so a linear that gradient dynamics track
those of a gradient dynamics on a linear
model for some amount of time right but
that's like a statement of the result
yes the motivating slide you had a
prompt was an appearance a set of
empirical selfish genre that you know
sort of empirical results instead in our
models you know with these sort of
things
no this is my state oh yeah there was
the ICL I think John was the little
thing for two years ago I know that was
that was on a state of the art right
this paper was about model this was
about generalization I'm only talking
about optimization right now this paper
is about generalization this statement
has nothing to do it
these I mean you can make extract a
statement about statistical error here
but it's not a strong state the this is
really an optimization thing I would say
it's saying that I mean that's what I'm
asking well in your mind what does this
say about the state of the art
motivation like that this would you be
able to give me you continue could ask
whether the initial configuration the
final configuration of pulse like this
they're not close really not close like
this so I mean that in your mind and
with God is does this I think it tells
you initial that you're you can get
training over small very quickly
initially in the first few steps
so it seems that one could come up with
empirical protocols and somehow see how
relevant this is to what's going on in
practical also I've said a word that
they're not quotes does that mean that
we run experiments and you know this
does not really capture what's going on
in in standard models yes there's
there's some careful papers not buying
me circle papers that say that this is
not yes and is there any evidence that
indicates otherwise
or is it depends on like your parameter
settings if you set the learning race
small it agrees well if you set the
learning rate big then no it disagrees
if you set a small aircrews yeah but
there are certain values that we usually
use in practice so and the ones like a
good test error disagree Cilicia pretty
simple question I hope but how should we
think about Hessians for models that
don't actually have Hessians you should
think about it as okay one quantitative
way to think about it is the change of
activation pattern which is a second
sigma prime is the activation pattern
and sigma prime prime is how much those
change in some measure
the Hessian is a border one over the has
seen itself without the Hessian you
don't care about the Hessians movement
while you carry we are worried about is
a gradient moving a lot because that
means your feature scheme is moving a
lot you want to ensure the feature
scheme does not move so you need about
the size of the movement of the feature
scheme which is the Hessian relative to
the size of the gradient because the
gradient multiplied by your movement is
your change in F that's why it's a
relative measure yeah so which Darby are
measured that has some potential because
still the size of the everything is just
awesome Park is the only parameter
moving is f so then the norm doesn't
matter but the the size of the parameter
depends on that sorry you should be L to
a spectrum
but everything in that paper pretend so
the only thing changing us out sure but
I mean just even the site also yeah if
you're careful you it's polynomial this
paper doesn't talk about I'm not sure
they talk
okay so somewhat this at least tells us
that at least locally we optimization is
not a big deal so perhaps you can
believe that if you your learning rate
initially is not very big you can get
your optimization error kind of small if
you try to use this kind of method to
get an analysis of generalization error
unsurprisingly since your feature scheme
is not changing what you'll find is
simply it has the same prediction
exactly as that of a kernel method the
kernel is called the neural tangent
kernel and your generalization bound
will look exactly like rate regression
will be something like like label Y
transpose kernel inverse y / n whole
thing under square root so that's some
generalization bound you can extract
from this style of analysis so I have no
I I don't think it's very tight in fact
I'll talk about later okay so let's look
a little bit more at generalization
error what's happening a very standard
found in generalization or some
complexity over N for example in kernel
methods it would be Y transpose K
inverse Y that's sort of the RK just
norm in Ridge regression
it could be VC dimension VC dimensions
roughly number of parameters times the
depth in feed-forward networks the
required list all kind of big they're
bigger the sample size which is exactly
what the I Claire paper was pointing out
it was pointing L essentially that the
number of parameters is roughly 30 20 30
times the number of samples in many
models and of course
of course so this slide is slow and from
naki or I think from telling you
actually who stole it from naughty and I
copied it from time
so we've all seen this many times I'm
sure by now so what they did in there my
clear paper is the number so you the
black line is a training curve and if
you took statistical learning you were
to kind of expect the red line kind of
goes well it doesn't it goes down so an
over parameterize ation does not seem to
hurt generalization in this case in fact
in this one example it kind of helps a
little you can improve your
generalization
even after interpolation and there's
even more evidence that number of
parameters are hurting if you plot the
imagenet top one error over time then
you see that in fact for these very very
big networks the top one error is quite
small it means be creasing here I mean
this is cherry pick from this paper but
there's clearly networks with 600
million parameters and it has passed
they are very low so throwing in
parameters in a non stupid way will not
hurt your generalization I'm here okay
so what's going on here let's turn to
margin theory and see what it tells us
so this margin theory is very classical
it basically says that if you're very
far from the decision boundary you
should be very good why is that
Pete Bartlett and Mendelssohn coalesced
this almost 20 years ago now basically
your generalization cap is upper bounded
by some complexity measure divided by
the margin so if you can ensure some
sort of Rademacher complexity that's
sort of size free independent of the
explicit independent of the width then
you can get good generalization error so
here's some papers that talk about how
to opera BAM the numerator here I'm only
going to talk about how to lower bound
the denominator okay so how do you get
solutions with good market let's look at
the simplest loss function with the
simplest regularization scheme is you
have logistic loss with a sum norm
regularizer for example weight DK l2
norm
you would kind of hope so this is the
Globo max margin this is the best you
can do if you search over all models in
your parametric family and you thought
you kept the one with largest margin
gamma star so you would hope you can get
gamma star and in fact if you do a very
good job of minimizing this regularized
functional for small lambda then you do
get gamma star so in other words if week
l2 regularization leads to assuming
optimization works week our two
regularization will get you very high
margin or the best possible March
okay this this proof is a simple unlike
a lot of you into this proofs I think
this is genuinely simple okay
the proof is essentially you write down
the logistic loss realize that logistic
loss when this argument is very small
can be approximated by Taylor's theorem
and I could see an exponential
exponential of a lot of terms added
together you only need to keep the
smallest one because the rest are
exponentially smaller okay so that this
line is Taylor's theorem and then this
one says if you add a bunch of like e to
the minus ten plus e to the minus
hundred
you only need to care about either minus
ten so only the smallest of these terms
matter that's why there's a min here and
then this from this you can kind of read
off the results if you lambda very small
it's saying let me use as much norm as
possible but among those I need a fit I
need to make the worst case margin good
so among solutions of the same norm we
prefer the largest margin okay so how
does so how does over parametrization
improve the margin this is completely
obvious if I have a network and this
site if I have a sub network of this
network the margin can only improve so
if you have a Rademacher bound that's a
independent of the explicit number of
parameters the margin is only improving
this denominator can only get bigger
okay so let's talk a little bit about
how to optimize when you have a
regularizer the first thing that realize
is that none of these results using n
key K and locally convex or whatever can
ever handle this the regularizer induces
a sort of tie breaking among the global
minimizer's and the global minimizer's
are not equivalent like you can have two
global minimizer's the unregular
eyestrain loss and they will have
drastically different regularization
effects so the regularization induces a
tiebreaking and now you really do need
to find like a global minimizer of this
regularize objective so how to do this
the answer is not fully satisfying but
we can say something so take a very very
very very wide network think of this as
like wider than anything you've seen
exponential in D or X Panetti whatever
infinite okay then run gradient descent
with a particular noise scheme then you
convert your global minimizer in
polynomial time polynomial in the
dimension and in one over epsilon
something like Pauly D over epsilon four
or something okay so gradient descent
I'm very very very over parameterize
networks converges to global minimizer's
so over parameterization does help even
when you have regularization the
mechanism in which it helps is very
different from this local convex
intuition the intuition here is that
when you're very very over primate
rising there's a descent direction in
function space but if you have a finite
a small width network you might miss the
function space because you might miss
the direction of this sign in the
function space that's essentially what
Frank wolf algorithm will do but
computing as Frank will sup is a
exponential time so but instead if you
had a ton of neurons and you add noise
then there might be an exponentially
small fraction of your neurons I see
this Frank wolf direction but then great
relu is homogeneous and then although
it's exponentially small signal it goes
up exponentially too and these things
carefully balanced and at the end you do
get a polynomial time result
so because the number is very large are
you
what's relationship for the ndk regime
this no more I'm Kiki and you guys
caught yeah you change anything NDK
Scott it's very fragile and so I know I
remember some of these results at that
on laminate extremely small you set
lambda and whatever way let's say you
want gamma Magnus point one and you set
lambda depending on that it's polynomial
time to get within constant a polynomial
iteration it's not pollen on with one
iteration is exponential time because
you have exponentially many parameters
some polynomial iterations
or time in the pde sense and one other
question so in the generation ban you're
talking about a size free Rademacher
bound right obtaining the margin with a
very light regularization parameter
president Ron a MicroBot might depend on
say norms which is n have to be balanced
against this resulting mark yes you
should think of whatever norms is this
let's concretely take the goal of which
one which is just a Frobenius norm of
everything then that would be weight
decay
okay all right so so you might ask um
okay so why add this regularizer I can
already get the global min of the
logistic loss without this
regularization term what am I getting
here is my stat sample complexity much
better and it turns out it is let's look
at a very simple data set on the first
two coordinates the data looks like this
it's like two eggs or essentially then
every other coordinate is just standard
normal so there's two coordinates that
have signal and that's the ones you want
to pay attention to the rest of the
coordinates are completely uncorrelated
with the label so they're noise
coordinates are kind of for you and they
exactly do full a kernel method a kernel
method is unable to localize onto the
first two dimensions so it has to look
over all dimensions and it pays sample
complexity at least d squared to get
some air last if you want R less than
some absolute constant you need to pay
at least d square samples because a
cardinal method to solve this problem
needs at least form pairwise degree to
polynomials that has complexity d
squared
however for that sort of to XOR
construction there's a neural net with
four neurons and then so then the sample
complexity of learning a neural net with
four neurons is something like four D
over N so D over and roughly so there's
a clear sample complexity separation
with regularizer you can learn with D
samples without regularizer uni at least
d square samples so regularization
explicit regularization or math you
yes yes yes good you might put it it's
not but we don't yeah it's not clear
yeah yeah
they might take exponential time we
don't know no we know it takes
exponential time how you scale things
but I can scale this so it takes you
expert but then you can increase your
learning rate anyway to analysis in the
specific city yeah I guess I should be
more precise to be more precise this one
is better than the NDK one let's play it
that way so then it covers the unregular
eyes and the regular ice case
okay so
so do you need regularization it turns
out you can do pretty well if you look
at these numbers without regularization
so like the gain here is not from
regularizing you gain 5% but if you just
change the architecture you can gain
around 10% so SGD without regularization
does already have very good
generalization perhaps it's not
state-of-art
but certainly the bulk is not from these
regularization methods okay
so let's turn to a simple example of
logistic regression so even if you have
separable logistic regression the
problems convex but not strongly or
strictly convex so there's many many
global minimizer's and you may be
wondering which one does it converge to
this is exactly what soldiery Hoffer and
cerebro asked a year or two ago and they
showed that this converges to the SVM
solution in a very precise sense if you
run gradient descent for a long long
long time
then you normalize because the norm
blows up you get exactly the auto SVM
solution after doing some normalization
this is quite amazing if you haven't
seen it before
there's all these directions why the
heck should gradient descent get the 1
of minimum how to norm that maximizes
the l2 margin right I mean this seems
maybe I should depend a loading rate how
you initialize it could depend on
anything and this result is quite stable
any learning rate that's stable it
converges to the whole to SVM solution
ok so then so what is then you might be
thinking what is special about gradient
descent let me write down gradient
descent in a very suggestive way I'm
just write it down so it's trying to
maximize the correlation you know yeah
because the logistic lost gradient is
never zero so it's impossible to have a
zero vanishing gradient even if you
this is in contrast to least-squares I
think which is where you're thinking yes
okay what was I saying yes this norm
okay the important thing is that you
write gradient descent in this
suggestive way so what it's saying is
that gradient descent is trying to
maximally decrease the lost value of the
function while paying infinitely small
amount of l2 norm the key thing is is
trying to use the least amount of Al to
norm to achieve this goal so now you
might ask why do I change a norm and
this gives you a family of steepest
descent algorithms and in fact you can
prove that for this entire family of
steepest descent algorithms you converge
the SVM given in that normal okay so for
example that one norm this is exactly a
form of boosting a to prove this a long
long time ago in s PhD that in fact does
maximize the l1 margin the same proof
works for all norms okay so some
examples coordinate descent which is
steepest ascent with respect to l1 norm
you're going to maximize l1 margin it's
not quite adaboost it's adaboost with
some damping step size so add a boost
with a dampened step size that maximizes
our margin adaboost itself does not sign
gradient method commonly used now the
save on communication this gets you some
L infinity bias and of course gradient
descent is steepest descent with respect
to l2 okay so that's kind of that's
great we understand logistic regression
very well that's sort of always the
starting point so now the question is
what does it do on deep networks if
you're if you're very very very
optimistic you may hope that it solves
max margin even if you do know
regularization because then you will
have some generalization bound that only
depends on this up here and that seems
good because now you can get the optimal
margin of course notice that this is an
SVM problem but it's a non convex SVM
problem now this SVM problem unlike the
linear case has many many stationary
points as first order stationary points
so I can order station points on a
global max so of course you cannot sort
prove that it converges to the global
Maximizer well you're able to prove is
that it converges the first order
optimal point on the following SVM this
is some nonlinear program it has first
order KKT conditions and assuming the
only assumption here is homogeneity then
if you do gradient descent exponential
loss logistic loss you get a first order
optimal point the first order stationary
point of this
okay so you wanted to prove it gets max
margin that's probably not possible
because you're running a local search
algorithm but at least you can
characterize that the whatever you
converge to is very special in the sense
that it's precisely a critical point of
a fairly intuitive optimization problem
okay
so I've talked about I didn't really
talk about the implicit regularization
of n key K but if you think about what
kernel methods is you can write down the
sort of implicit bias of NPK or the
inductive bias of it as sort of you're
trying to find the thing that best that
maximizes the margin the worst-case
margin but you stay infinitely close to
your initialization so this top one
theta hat K is exactly what would happen
if you did n TK on logistic loss and
terminated after some amount of time a
very long time you had approximately get
maximum margin maximum with respect to a
different sense in the sense that you
have to stay infinitely close to this
ball what the this previous result by us
and Haiphong Liu and Jen we chose that
actually you get a stationary point of
this following program and of this
program you're letting the prompter move
infinitely far from its initialization
so it's completely forgetting where it's
initializing it's running forever and
ever
which you'll always do when you have a
logistic loss and when you run forever
and ever
you try to maximize the margin okay
these are of course two endpoints of an
extreme case on one of these you're
trying to say infinitely close to your
initialization the other you're moving
infinitely far so they're very different
with endpoints probably in my opinion
what's interesting is probably when this
is not quite zero you're going slightly
further than the linear regime but
you're clearly not going to this super
asymptotic regime
you've deviated slightly from the N key
K and what is happy there we don't
really know but I think that's probably
likely to correspond to closer to
practice than the other end point
because things like large learning rate
finite width will cause you to sort of
stay infinitely close yeah okay so the
final thing I want to talk about is how
does architecture matter so I've told
you kind of that gradient descent
asymptotically the bias it gets you is
an l2 regularization on all of the
parameters but that's sort of
uninteresting why should you ever care
about the parameters again parameters
have no meaning in your own nets the
only thing that matters at the end is
your function f this is all you see a
test time the parameter is just a way to
encode F so what you should really ask
is how does this bias translate over
here so what is the bias on the
prediction function and this is clearly
where architecture matter so for example
here 1 3 & 4
there was no regularization the
algorithm was just SGD the only thing
that changes is the architecture yet you
get a huge improvement in the test error
luckily I don't know the answer for
neural nets but in linear networks
there's a very crisp answer you can take
a linear function write it as a product
of matrices then if you have outer
regularization on w's which comes from
gradient descent it translates a shot in
quasi norm on theta on the linear
function okay so regardless of the depth
and the width the prediction function
class stays linear you know you can
write a linear map a matrix as a product
as one matrix as a product of five
matrices is still matrix the function
class number changes or simply varying
the parameterization combined with
algorithm changes the inductive bias
here and here you can characterize in a
very precise sense but whatever gradient
can descend converges to is a stationary
point of some problem with this shot and
quasi norm okay a similar phenomenon in
convolutional networks same thing you
can take a linear convolutional net and
write it as of comp of predictors you'll
also get a quasi norm except now it's
sparsely instead of on the singular
values okay
no it stops its learning like it's
always changing zone on versatility the
function is infinitely flat so in fact
you can even grow the life
some solar league rate of those
convergence yeah you need sufficient
design there's nothing
okay so some random thoughts let me
finish so of course we've seen now that
by training Colonel training neural nets
now stay close to initialization using a
kernel classes so how'd it go beyond
kernels UN's I mentioned this yesterday
and of course one thing missing here is
how will distributional assumptions help
most of these results have not used
distributional assumptions in any
meaningful way I would say I mean
there's a lot of results about learning
single relu single convolutional filters
they use Gaussian assumptions of course
and those argue and even then you can
see the Gaussian are helping you that
much there were other ways to learn it
just maybe not quite gradient descent so
what are some reasonable distributional
assumptions that can help us learn
things via kernels don't really depend
on the distribution their optimization
at least so what happens right after the
ndk regime we figure out the end point
in a sense we figured out what happens
locally we've figured out what happens
if you move infinitely far but the whole
middle I don't know it's kind of
interesting in architecture design an
inductive bias so you know people come
out with new architectures every week
and how does this change the inductive
bias of SGD if I do
SGD on ResNet versus amoeba net block
then you know what is changing here
let's say I just use STD on both but the
functions I learn are different how are
they different
and why does amoeba net whatever
generalize better
[Applause]
nothing GD is just easier to analyze
most of the results hold for a skewed
yeah that was for single oh no that's a
matrix this one's a matrix this one's a
matrix you minimize there's two results
one is you minimize cross-entropy
with explicit weight DK you get the
quasi norm second one is you minimize
cross-entropy
with TD no there's no optimization these
are statements about global minimum okay
the first statement is a statement about
global minimum the second statement is
invoking this following theorem this
says that you convert a force or the
optimal point of a problem an SVM where
this is the Shatan clause anymore
so the inductive bias of having deep
that's in a linear network using
logistic loss is getting closer to is a
crank this is about first-order
okay so gradient descent the algorithm
is involved here it's about gradient
descent you run gradient descent
something happens and what happens is a
converge to a first-order stationary
point of a problem where this is a shot
in normal it may not be the global
minimum because it's non convex but it's
a stationary point of the shaft and